et Christophe Gaillet nous a rejoint
Christophe et bien il est propriétaire
d'une boutique à Orléan qui vend des
produits québécois et canadien bonjour
Christophe alors qu'est-ce qu'on trouve
dans votre boutique bah mout chose des
produits québécois typique C sirop
d'érable bien sûr et plusieurs de ces
dérivés notamment des biscuits et aussi
bien sûr des thé tisanes
àéra des alcools aussi notamment le
sortilège alors justement qu'est-ce que
vous nous vous avez ramené à déguster
expliquez-nous un petit peu alors j'ai
ramené donc là ça c'est la boîte
emblématique du sirop d'érable qu'on a
qu'on trouve aube nous en France on n
pas l'habitude de voir sous cette forme
exactement après là vous avez le site de
glace qui est du du comment dirait c'est
comme les v char mais c'est avec de la
pomme qui est quand même doit être assez
sucré non non très peu en vérité ça se
sert bien glacé donc faut le mettre au
frigo une 24 heur avant et une heure
avant au congélateur et ça et ça c'est
un whisky c'est ça alors ça c'est un
whisky ouais ça c'est whisky à consommer
avec ave modération éid pour on
apprécier toute sa saveur donc c'est un
whisky à base de sirop d'érable et donc
un whisky qu'on peut consommer comme
digestif et ici on a des des petits
gâteaux au siropérable Sébastien si vous
voulez goûter allez-y nous on va goûter
juste après c'est quoi les
incontournable sur sur quel produit
est-ce qu'il faut s'arrêter des produits
que nous français on a pas l'habitude
c'est surtout le le sirop d'érable qui
est très populaire malgré tout ça rentre
dans les mers les Français on consomment
de plus en plus et puis qu'on utilise
donc soit pour cuisiner
pour sucrer son café ou aussi ses crèpes
bien sûr les pancakes